[Musique]
let me in the mighty nina wang france
face à ambri et lilia qui est indécise
et tiennent à la vie ce réseau elon musk
est prêt à donner 6 milliards de dollars
pour lutter contre la faim dans le monde
en vendant des actions tesla mais
l'homme le plus riche du monde pose une
condition que l'onu qui explique
clairement sur twitter comment une telle
somme pourrait résoudre ce problème
ce qu'il veut c'est une comptabilité
transparente afin que le public puisse
voir précisément comment l'argent serait
dépensé bien à tous qu'il est
c'était généraux donne donne donne
attend jamais que soit la personne qui
t'a donné qui doit te rendre mais ça
revient quand tu danses un boomerang ton
voit le titre lui reprend derrière
multiplié par dix
après son appel à sauver le monde en
écosse boris johnson a préféré l'avion
au train pour rentrer à londres nous
avons d'ailleurs les images du décollage
[Musique]
ça veut dire il y avait plus de place
dans le train c'est un trucage et voir
évidemment parce qu'un avion peut pas
faire ça sinon les gens seraient malades
[Musique]
pourquoi à la fin du monde n'est pas
pour demain et ils ont raison on efface
pour le coup à une désinformation n'est
absolu sur le sujet par exemple et les
écolos qui répètent que le niveau de la
mer est en train de monter mais ils
montrent de quoi 1 2 mm par an yann ça
fait 10 cm en 50 ans on va pas pleurer
pour dix centimètres on n'est pas la
copine détiennent
[Rires]
la pilule masculine existe bien mais
aucun laboratoire n'est prêt à la
commercialiser mais alors pourquoi cette
réticence et bien les labos disent qu'il
n'y a pas de marché parce que les hommes
ne souhaitent pas gérer la contraception
dans le couple mais les choses sont en
train de changer avec les nouvelles
générations
37% des hommes de moins de 30 ans se
disent prêts à prendre une pilule
contraceptive
s'il est à rembourser et ce même avec
leurs effets secondaires
alors que nous
et en fait faut être un homme parce que
si on lit ce que vous dites
représentations les hommes gagnent mieux
sont tranquilles son chef de famille ont
des belles voitures etc et les femmes en
revanche est horrible elles se font
violer elle se prostitue elle parle pas
de sexe enfin
ben voilà il ya quand même des beaux
côtés nom est une fille
[Musique]
les mecs
et puis aussi des méthodes naturelles
sans hormones dont vous souhaitez nous
parlent et je crois guillot alors vous
allez voir la plus connue c'est ce qu'on
appelle à tort le slip chauffons alors
non ce n'est pas un petit radiateur
regardez vous allez tout comprendre
c'est une sorte de petit sous vêtements
qui fait remonter les testicules en
dehors des bourses en se rapprochant du
corps et bien la température augmente et
la production de spermatozoïdes s'arrête
alors il ya quand même une condition il
faut le porter au moins quinze heures
par jour oui ça fait loin voilà mais moi
ça fonctionne est ce que tu es seul
qu'il tient coi et ben il ya déjà bah
c'est pas possible
scott on discute quoi où habitent ou un
peu plus civilisée yeux si
lisez mon autre mois
why don't you were ring
mais non personne vous avez dit nous a
pas dit qu'il me fallait comme en france
si vous me remettez pareil
j'avais j'ai forcé la même
à l'école catholique exactement la même
qu'est-ce qu'on fait face à un miroir
on le regarde nungesser on dit je suis
un crime
je veux refaire les deux chines crime au
regard des la reine elizabeth 2 95 ans
quand bénin a été aperçu au volant de sa
voiture une jaguar elle devait pas
rester chez elles tranquille bah écoute
à la visite vers un petit tour sa balle
au bond
alors une bonne nouvelle je vous disais
pour les britanniques parce que depuis
j'ai depuis plusieurs semaines on s' y
avait beaucoup d'inquiétudes 1 sur son
état de santé ça va faire très attention
quand on soulève ou quand on lâche une
caisse
comme ça
bon on s'est peut être facile on va
continuer
et on a déjà des fous rires qui sont
enregistrés chez moi par commencé comme
ça voilà donc au beau jeu
avec un spécialiste en quelques instants
voilà encore
hélas il est là
à droite me we can am
et
et merci pas de gros parce que c'est
très dur
pour moi
on déguste dans un instant mais d'abord
on vous dégustez bush et remaniés enfin
en vous et en déguste
on exige de moi j'aime pas le passé mais
j'adore les crudités les quoi j'adore
les crudités la crevette et des crudités
mercredi les crudités c'est à dire aller
méditer sur les trucs qui épate là
où marc
les crevettes et les coquilles saint
jacques les moules non alors ça c'est
les crustacés clara pas la qualité quand
on décrit une cloche les mots utilisés
pour les décrire ce rapporte également
au corps humain c'est tout à fait
intéressant la partie supérieure on la
nomme le cerveau ici vous avez l'épaule
lors on crache pas mal et les cloches
ont des noms des cerveaux une table
notamment roi
une lettre v et du riz verrait là j'ai
hâte la lettre v et du riz table
véritable véritable vernis dans le
vernis non
ok
avec le temps
avec le temps va tout s'en va
l'autre
qu'on croyait
notre compte je sais tout vous parle de
moi ce soir je vais ainsi
[Applaudissements]